Yeah. Well in terms of that. The early days and we were all pioneering tog's who is sort of. You could class. Credit.
Classified as rugged individualists to. Strangely enough wanted to live together and share their lives together and.
One example of that was a local farmer that.
When my new arrangement with him where we could direct humphrey on his land.
And he would get some of the company for his cattle and. We would use the rest of it somehow.
Comfrey was going to be the miracle plant of the seventy's and eighty's and whatever and.
So we got they way that country plants are ready to play that he'd plant up the paddocks that was loose
and things like that and we started planting and then we.
Then we realized we weren't sure how the irrigation would work and have all of this.
They run off from these dayroom with seed and water and so on would get to each plant.
I mean the story in that paddock about fifteen
or more of us all with a different idea of exactly how the irrigation to what the two of us just know a little bit go
there particularly.
I did is a carrier of guys who are getting company should work that sort of gives you know idea of the sort of.
I suppose those were the early days in terms of us understanding had group decisions work and all of that
and we were determined to use consensus but.
We didn't have a clear idea of the prices that we could use to get to some sort of decision so you know we just i get
in the sun for two and.
And until everyone got really really frustrated i think and decide on something or maybe the family came along
and sort of the set i can't remember. Anyway then. Oh yeah. Yeah.
I mean we in the early days up of course because we were just beginning in there were a lot of decisions to be mine
and we didn't know each other that well. But. But also because we were just beginning is that.
Mating and using consensus. We met for a full day every. Week. Meetings.
We did have an agenda and things like that and. Gradually got the hang of having one per cent of the scylla type.
Take the role of. Guarding the meeting. So on whereas these days. We make for half a day.
Maybe only a few hours once a month and. So that's just the.
Just the changing and need to spend time in decision making.
And we were before the china as well one interesting thing that means.
Saying that the early people were calling me a meeting.
That's true of the sort of the people that came within the first four or five years.
And then there was a sort of a gap and. A bunch of different sort of people moved on after six or seven or eight years.
And these people sora set up community they saw water systems in the ground.
Roads working as a sort of community that had its rules and structure as a way of making decisions together.
Set of friendships a past history. Happening. Established buildings.
The whole way of life that they could just move into. Greit now and and. Very cheap and.
Just totally inviting into a different sort of person i'm not saying. In any way.
You know in fear or anything like that. Lovely people and different. And that's. Course a little bit of.
Not exactly friction but. Disgruntled with some tell and because the advantage of being a pioneering person.
In some ways is that you're looking around and looking at how things are going and taking initiative.
Really being responsible for what's around and really being engaged with the land with the community.
You know whether it's a process of being together or relationships or something that needs doing when the land
or building that we. Neha whatever.
Where is the sort of second type of people if i can call them that doesn't tend to engage in that same way.
So easily sets taken from me. Just prompting people saying hey. If you want to contribute.
Have that building a visitor's hess.
That have a great thing and things that were immediately apparent to me just would.
Apparent to them because it all looks set up and their point of view.
Where is my vision is still going to be running amok. And i imagine. I'm not quite so.
Well i'm not quite sure what to imagine but that will go.
We'll go into some other phases that attract a different sort of person again
and that will bring it's an interesting dilemma is and. Compromises and so on.
This is what we decided in the early dice part of our idealism and then more than idealism. That.
Knowing he could run their house that they built. We don't have shares we just have donations.
And you can't likely do anything except what you can sort of carry off and you can more or less.
And that's what people have had to do people who have left. Have left. So you can say with nothing.
Will die some have been given money as well. But by sickly the it is known on issues of houses is a policy.
Which means that we as a community. My. Might give some money. To a departing. Member or may not and. That was part of.
That was idealism thing well it wouldn't be great to write down the structure of land
and i'm an issue going to strategy because it just seems to increase the gap between rich and poor
and of course lots of trauma in society and. It seems wrong who.
You know he says we can and then what a ridiculous notion in a way. But it was also thinking that.
Well that would show you were really committed if you come into this community and you.
You knew that you couldn't speculate on it.
Infected with worse and you couldn't depend on more he way with anything at all. And so it meant that no one could.
Would come here. Because i really just wanted to live with us.
Which seemed like a principle criterion as far as we're concerned by things the idealism
and wanting to change the world in the practical thing of having people who are committed.
But that has made a lot of difficulty in recent years with for example my ex partner.
Mother of my boys who grew a way from the community didn't want to participate in one of the sort of. Guy strata.
What if you had say. And. And who nonparticipation really began to an annoying other people.
But how can you make someone participate and so on.
And she started saying well i want to leave but i want money for the house which we built together.
And we decided that that was fair enough and then a woman or a couple came that really wanted to leave here
and they said yeah well that's fair enough. We'll pay the community some money for the privilege of living in that.
Already built house and not having to build one and. The community can decide whether to pass it on to my ex.
And that's what happened. But. They were very worried about that setting a precedent.
But by protests far as i'm concerned both president's been sitting there.
People are going away with nothing and going away with something so.
It leaves the pair and the hands of the community which. I'm really happy with.
At the moment because i think we make decisions really well.
We do listen to each other carefully and spend time when there is an important decision to be married. And.
So i thought i have a lot of confidence in that i'm aware that it could go.
Could go wrong with i'm not quite sure how at the moment. We will lose. The legal structure is that it.
For a minute for around lawyers.
Solicitors point of view it would be almost impossible for someone to take control of the land and try
and sell it from under us we've set up a structure that is both confusing and very fickle too. To reward.
But then in terms of.
Sanctioning anyone's behavior we have
when you have nothing at all nothing legal at all whereas for example estrada title or something like that does this.
All the rules that a community might make up on the strata title get fixed in the lore
and they can call in the place to enforce it and we can do that. And we've through a big thought.
Strange about having to do that really. Bit. Last august. Yeah. That's when a lot to us.
Of course has been pretty thick. Preaching between people and misunderstandings and. Hurt and anger.
But there is this climate in which i have a time things get result people to do the hates die down they go
and talk to each other and. And work things through integrated disagree or whatever. And i think that's.
That's a function of. You know i values.
And just who happens to have come here but it's also a function of who was the truth or. See it so.
It's also a function of the size of the group and. We have twenty adults here and with about twenty children.
Which means that i family. A lot of sole parent families and you come here.
And i think if it got up to about thirty adults would find factions forming. Fairly wary of that.
So net net so always have a great conflict because there's lots of lovely people i'd love to come and live here.
People some of whom i feel much more affinity with than some of the men with you know about. You know.
Oh yeah ok well the first thing is when in a way to stop but. A little bit.
Means movement is a name is often in question and i think it's worth questioning because it's not.
It's not like a normal political movement with. With a particularly agenda and i know. In a political organization.
And people joining in a much as a rule or petition or something it's more.
And that's totally appropriate in what's called the men's movement because. Because while.
Women had to find their strength and power into saudi i'm able to stand up
and be counted said a spray can be tied properly and so on we respected men in general had that.
What white men didn't have was an ability to be more introspective
and say life is an inner journey as much as an outer chief meant and. And so i lodged.
A mess picked of the men's movement. Is more than a personal growth.
Coming down to what i understand oneself as a man and. As a human and as a as being alive on this wonderful planet.
This time and so on. So i've been involved.
With working with man and being with with men in sort of consciousness raising groups. For about eight years.
And that kind that of. Running groups. Called the spade to impel and graves.
That was particularly focusing on one's emotional response to the state of the planet particularly the possibility of
nuclear war in those days. And that can lead to just being part of green protests and.
Realizing that we needed to know each other better and to communicate better to really.
Protest effectively says that are working with people and learning. And training and so on. You know i don't know.
Not in particular more this area not this.
This communities a particular buddy from communities particularly socially and environmentally only into it and.
If you make a list of all the projects people. Members have been involved with it's really long and quite impressive.
But in terms of getting into and working with i mean there's one other man that was living here at the time
and sort of a member called cane. And he and i had discussed.
How women seem to have you having such a good time together in their in their groups
and their workshops i have that are women and we were sort of envious and jealous and.
So it can men really have friendships that same as close as women seem to be and.
You know that's what i was asking myself can i have camaraderie with. With men without having to go to war for.
It was a real question. I had no idea of. I really wanted. Whether it was possible.
I thought one of the first workshops we organized which was a long weekend workshop was called the ends that way again.
Then within that it was on. Was only anzac day weekend. And when we true. If you leave. Looking at power and authority.
Can you not
but having had experience with designing money which helps we design one particularly for men with all sorts of excel
as that would bring these issues up and we can discuss and discover more about ourselves as men. And we had to be turn.
Bet twenty five men came along and we put them through all sorts of exercises and. Yeah.
One of the principle exercises we used in that. We're shot was what we called a circle of us elation.
And it more or less was a reenactment. Just acting out in a panic. What happens to a boy in a mile as he grows up.
So we go. First of all but.
So the matching around militarily like you have to get do at school or you might if you went to cadets and so on
and telling them off and so on then we asked them to just sort of mill around and break into pairs
and look at each other's. Look.
Looking at each other's eyes and imagine the other person childhood friend and he thought about that and then.
Break up again and. Look in another man's eyes and imagine in them to be. The teacher that last year around. And then.
Maybe the adolescent that. That was you believe me when i've only gradually built up a picture of the.
Different events in miles life. That tend to push to draw them into isolation drive them into.
Having to take care of themselves and not and and. Be wary of everyone else especially other miles.
Which happens in all sorts of i've it uncover why.
And then we go to everyone to get in a circle facing outwards to sort of a tight circle and just start walking.
Until you can no longer see any just in your peripheral vision maybe you could see another man so we're very wide
circle and much panic and ask them to feel what that was like my.
Express it in some way peeing in others who are just yelling and screaming and others were just silent and and.
Just standing there feeling it.
Because they've been in the group we've been sharing they walked away from it
and that was just sort of mirrored for us.
What it's been like growing up from feeling close and exactly whose small room valued and.
Being able to share and being able to be in moment and so on.
To being a man where you know i said i didn't you take care of yourself and you got to be in control and.
And you kind of cry and so on and.
Quite a powerful exercise numa good men to turn around face each other maybe make eye contact way across the paddock
and start walking in and see what that feels like and. You know for myself.
Although i feel the agony at being on the outside of the circle i also felt real apprehension of coming back in class
because i was so i felt there that was what i was used to. And so we did. Sort of.
Coming closer and there was joy in that. And when we sang together in a beach other and so you know that's one.
One exercise that. Kim and i have often used in workshop scenes. This to dramatically illustrate what happens to me.
To them so it's because most men don't even realise that that's happened i didn't like it's a process of.
Like a fish discovering what water is. Well let's let's walk on site it's really a movement to speak.
It's just a whole different main that are quite interested in.
Well i might come out of a broken up relationship with suddenly realising that got no one to talk to in the apartment
and has lots of support where they might really think you know i'd like to be friends with men
and not have this sort of stand off. Beer in hand relationship. In terms of that. And so it's.
I don't know what to say about it in this area and this is still.
A lot of men most of who know each other because it's only a small group so if i may be a couple of hundred.
Who are willing who really want to look at themselves as men understand themselves as women find out what it is to be a
little. You know. In a generation. Because everything else has been. They all roles.
Has been ripped away from a sort of being the provider and so on
and even the protector can easily be because that involves going to war in a kind of free with that anymore.
So i can no longer be a provider or. Or protect an it necessarily.
And why that before that the industrial revolution and so on ripped away.
The ancient traditions of what it was to be a man.
I passed on here to each that we've sort of more or less lost remans i think has been more intact because.
From mother to daughter.
Mothers and daughters tended to stay at home and share things with men are seen as they got old enough
or at work who are the factories. The apprenticeship system.
Perhaps kept up a bit of the old traditions of what is history and then but that's broken down these days as well.
So it's refining and also just making it press room for.
What sort of relationships we won't win each other let's try them. You know.
And that's been a fantastic thing to be involved with i love nearly every moment of it really enjoy it being paddled
facilitating means groups just weekly groups where particular thing. Used.
You know like father being a father and father or father in law.
Or one's own father or mother or six zero zero six and intimacy.
All work or just untold number of frames we can used as a discussion point. And there's a lot of exercises and.
Things we can do together have fun to get to know each other better. That's greeted with a lot of suspicion.
Because this.
Rampant fear in men are getting closer because they've been trying not to be so they get very angry if i say i mean.
Doing what they were told not to me and that generally critz gets called homophobia which is.
Is a sort of misnomer that's generally supposed to mean fear of guy i mean.
But i think it's really fear of each other the fear of other men in general women especially.
Fear of any man that says well i'm quite happy.
Being uncomfortable being close and talking about intimate things with you. So there's that reaction and this is all.
Personally i've had very little. Almost no criticism from women. About what i do. And i know other men that have.
So i think it's. You know i'm not sure why that is that. I'm quite you know i. In terms of feminism i'm really feel.
I i would write that. To feminist think is and all the women that have put their lives and their family and.
And selling on the line to make changes. You know society. The second feiss that made. And and steal.
I also react to some elements of feminism with this seems to be a business against me in that i would call sort of
sexist. Because it is this generalized generalized distrust. Which i can understand.
But when i'm talking with a thinking woman i expected her to rise above that and. But i've really come across that.
Bitterness aimed directly at me. In what i do.
Mostly this incredible support because women seem to be able to see much more easily than men can.
What influences on men from birth and also how men behave. Evidently because of them. So i do teach.
Men's issues in thai sometimes in other places and and.
You know the way a locked case is just actually draw out other people's experiences and the women can talk.
Much more easily about. What i would call means oppression. Then the main. In general in the classes.
And then it can be quite a painful topic for. Quite a few people to do. So. So the different responses.
I think in mine lee out of one's personal pine in the area of gender. This goes back generations.
But with different genders are sort of. Done to each other expected to each other. We didn't have a set s.
It was out to be self-sufficient vegetables and fruit or whatever with that was never.
Well i would call but he thought. They were really more accurately coolest buddy village or something like that.
That's a great relief i think it's a bit of a mistake to put so much of it into something for what.
To me is a fairly sort of a shall i go to be self-sufficient not rather be integrated not think most people here.
Would rather feel that they're making a difference to society as a whole
and therefore a part of society rather than going outside saw him trying to be separate. So yeah.
For myself having young. Tweens and getting a party together of course i went on the dollar many of us did to survive.
And.
I suppose a critic might say why don't you go out get a job to earn the money to come back and then do the pottery
and so on but i just was. Motivated to get this community up and running i didn't want to leave it for a moment.
I really wanted to be part of it. Every day and. And that meant. You know i couldn't money.
Just being there until i got the pottery up such as me living there
and being on the dollar you know i got kicked off the golf more
or less for that attitude i suppose in those days they were encouraging people to set up businesses of their own.
And so really before i had finished the pottery buildings to my satisfaction the market. Efficient. Sort of factory.
Got kicked off and we went on again. That's my partner and months later because we just had to you know.
So social security is really being unable to our community get to get up
and running as quickly as it has to be very high. To run in money and build this price as well. And we feel. Well.
We can justify that in the sense that well at least we're constructing something with that money from the government if
you like something of lasting importance and. So now not so many people on the dial. And the one.
There was a school because they all had the pottery going. Couldn't say it was very lucrative. And there was another.
Business he called if it was trading which was importing things from india
and also making up your creams unless i enjoy it so that. That was supporting some people.
Besides that they've been really industries. Well in the community. People have gone out to work.
And that's how it is now. With people working in these moral the area and teaching the whole range of different things.
The buddy buddy buddy made this. Synonymous with enlightenment or understanding.
The truth or something like that
and so we knew more arrogant moments we can call ourselves from as of enlightenment you know i think.
I sort of shifted where shrinking it was so shocking that. You know in some ways you could say that. You know we've.
We've helped start preschools and. Forest. Saving organizations and. Home birthing plea.
Things and hot politics conferences and. Well manner of things. So in that way. In terms of.
Relative enlightenment press we've helped along the way a little bit where.
What was the angle of your question the just body thing. You know it's a nice clean. Relates to shorten. Increase.
And i think most people here are sort of proud of it and. There is such a thing as group morale and.
Good you feel about the place and which includes head would you feel about the layman the image that we have.
And generally we do feel good about it we've been criticized by the more i'm feral.
When he say he peace in the hills as being middle class and
and to each one of them in the said middle class upper class think you know just taking the heat out of it. But. That.
And that's because we read and learn. We have had slightly different values then.
You could say the alternative society in general we. Because we haven't had dived on the place.
And we've been you know part of running these meditation retreats and so on so.
Sometimes we've been criticized as being pure and. Things. You know ridiculous things like that. With. Oh.
Well most people here. We're aware of the situation in the world where and. By sickly that. The west.
Lives on the back of. Goodwill and. Through the institution of. A third world debt and and.
Differing process for commodities and peoples labor and so on.
And we're also well aware that there's limited resources in the world
and that not everyone can be brought up to a western standard. With a cow or fridge. You know.
All the things that we enjoy in this country. Just the. The environment is groening.
Bearing that at the moment mean and possibly for your pot little and if we bring all of india and china
and so on up to that standard. So the only way. In terms of that. Environmental outlook on a global outlook to. To.
A lot to be sustainable on this planet is for people to expectations in the last else to drop a bit.
And so we've sort of consciously done that.
But then the other side of that is that it's just like jesus said it's easier for a camel to hold through the eye of a
needle and it is for rich men to get into heaven this is the truth
and that is that too many material possessions clottey or. You know laws. Tend to make more attached to things.
And therefore it's not so easy to change and move with a way where you need to go in on your spiritual journey and.
So those two values that are going to mingle with each other the global perspective in a spiritual perspective.
To mean that. And they come down to. That there is some benefit in having a simpler lifestyle. Less material position.
Less pressured lifestyle. Say i don't consider. I consider myself pretty rich.
I've been thinking about this recently because i've been working in time.
And just thinking about other people's lives compared to my own and where i don't. I don't have very many overheads.
It's true i don't own my house.
But i'm not putting out anything on a date and anything i belong to it just stays there for many years and.
So my wage guys a lot further.
In other people's money who are renting or paying off a mortgage or whatever a little and running to them.
Buying the newest gadget. So i consider myself a really wealthy. Bicycling because i'm pretty happy with what i've got.
But.
But more than that because i have instead of putting all my work into superannuation
and so on i put it into establishing a community around me
and my security is in the money so much as the people in my life. Time will tell which ones in a bit a bit of it.
For the moment i much prefer this one thank you.